[Musique]
waouh 150 personnes ça fait beaucoup de
monde cette année on m'a challengé avec
le thème
oser
oser c'est sortir de sa zone de confort
et saisir les opportunités qui se
présentent à nous c'est surmonter nos
peurs et nos doutes pour aller de
l'avant en montant sur scène ce soir
devant une centaine de personnes je sors
de ma zone de confort et saisis une
opportunité en étant speaker pour C
tdex est-ce que l'on peut dire que j'ai
osé
oui parfait alors bonne
soirée
je
plaisante aujourd'hui mesdames et
messieurs j'aimerais saisir l'occasion
de vous parler d'un sujet qui me tient
énormément à
cœur
l'éducation pour vous amener à l'essence
de mon propos j'aimerais tout d'abord
vous poser quelques
questions qui parmi vous a suivi une
formation en économie ù travaille dans
le secteur financier et investi une
partie de son
revenu
merci qui parmi vous investit une partie
son revenu sans être dans le domaine
financier dernière
question qui parmi vous n'investit pas
du
tout votre pens à de marier un ou une
millionnaire n'est-ce pas malin bah vous
avez tout compris osez marier une
personne millionnaire je ne vois pas ce
que je fais
ici mais alors pourquoi vous a-je posé
ces questions alors que le sujet de mon
intervention est
l'éducation pour clarifier ceci je vais
vous emmener dans mon
passé quand j'étais petite ma grandmaman
m'a un jour dit et le dit
économise tous les petits sous que tu
peux sur ton compte bancaire à tes 18
ans tu auras un gros sous et il te sera
utile pour ton
futur pour chaque s que tu mets de côté
j'ajoute 5
francs vous imaginez 5 francs c'était
énorme pour moi quand j'avais 7 ans et
ça l'IT encore aujourd'hui puisque mon
rendement direct s'est monté à 10
% aucune banque ne pouvait la conc
ané alors sans même me parler d'aller à
de la vie elle m'avait donné goût à
l'épargne à son échelle elle avait
démocratisé la finance et ce qu'elle ne
sait pas c'est que son investissement
dans mon éducation m'aura sauvé la
mise
alors comment cette éducation a
transformé ma vie il y a un peu plus
d'un an tout allait bien pour moi
j'avais un job de rêve des collègues en
or des amis présents une routine
sportive que
j'adorais aucun stress aucun problème de
santé quand je vous parle d'un job de
rêve c'était un job qui avait du sens à
mes yeux car je contribuais à
démocratiser l'investissement chose très
importante dans notre société j'allais
répondre aux questions d'auditeur de
Rouge fm chaque lundi en vulgarisant les
concepts en finances et en
investissement j'allais également sur
des événements financiers pour parler
avec d'autres femmes du domaine et
j'adorais ça à tel point que j'en
parlais sur tous mes réseaux
sociaux et justement le 29 juin sur un
événement financier vers 14h je publie
une story sur mon compte Instagram avec
la mention BEST JOB
ever et 2h plus tard tout
s
il aura suffi de 2 minutes pour que ma
vie de rêve parte en fumée été 2022
crash
crypto le matin de l'événement on me
convoque à un meeting en ligne pour
l'après-midi même à 16h je me connecte
en 2 minutes on m'explique que
l'entreprise doit se séparer de moi sur
le moment je ne comprends pas mais
d'autres collègues seront également
licenciés dans certains dans des
conditions bien
pires alors au revoir les collègues
géniaux au revoir mes lundis à la
radio au revoir le marketing pour
démocratiser
l'investissement et bonjour le
chômage au chômage on me donne un dé
d'attente d'un mois puis on ne m'roit
que le 70 % d'un salaire plafonné par
l'État vaut mieux donc avoir eu un bon
salaire avant en licenciement pas
d'enfant à charge et des économies pour
tenir heureusement pour moi si vous
rappelez de mon histoire j'ai toujours
été inspiré par ma
nana mais ce n'est pas le cas de tout le
monde et vous comprendrez bientôt
pourquoi alors quand je vous dis que mon
empire s'est effondré mais que vous
n'entendez parler que d'un licenciement
vous devez vous dire bon
elle exagère alors attachez votre
ceinture je vais vous emmener dans ma
longue
descente septembre toujours pas de place
de travail trouvé dans mon secteur le
stress monte petit à petit je prends de
semaines de vacances non réméré par le
chômage naturellement pour me
ressourcer quelques semaines plus tard
je mets un terme à ma relation amoureuse
novembre je sens des douleurs dans mon
corps je pars aux urgences et on me
diagnostique des infections internes on
ne saura pas me dire la
cause alors quand on tombe au chômage
que son quotidien est chamboulé et qu'on
enchaîne les problèmes de santé vaut
mieux garder son esprit
occupé je n'ai certes plus mon travail
ni la radio pour vulgariser démocratiser
investissement mais j'avais mes réseaux
sociaux alors
entre deux consultations aux urgences je
lance ce projet super important à mes
yeux l'éducation en
finances décembre je passe au bloc
opératoire 5 jours se passent sans
encombre du moins en apparence
malheureusement 7 jours plus tard retour
aux urgences et on m'opère pendant la
nuit
en tout d'octobre à mai 2023 ce sera
quatre opérations sous anesthésie
générale si on en était resté là je me
serais d chanceuse mais naturellement
après les opérations arrivent les
factures pour
chacune 3000 francs à payer sous 30
jours puis naturellement en mai arrive
la taxation des impôts
ah vous la connaissez cette fameuse
enveloppe
tique n'est-ce
pas merci mes économies construites au
fil du
temps tous ces événements partagés avec
vous ce soir m'ont fait comprendre que
l'éducation financière é importante pour
son présent pour son avenir et également
pour le futur des autres
autre alors à tous les parents dans
cette salle aujourd'hui j'ai envie de
vous dire osez investir dans l'éducation
financière de vos enfants d'ailleurs
Nelson Mandela
disait les enfants sont notre avenir
investir en eux c'est investir dans le
futur je sais pas si vous êtes déjà fait
cette même réflexion mais de la primaire
à la secondaire
aucune formation financière n'est
dispensée notre système éducatif néglige
ces compétences financières essentielles
au profit de sujets qui laissent nos
poches
fragiles à l'école on nous apprend à
compter à rédiger des dissertations et à
connaître les capitales des pays tiens
qui parmi vous se souvient de toutes les
capitales de même est-ce que savoir
discerner s'il s'agit d'une dérivée une
fonction tangente ou affine vous aidera
réellement éviter la précarité à l'âge
la retraite parce que bon si le système
de retraite s'effondre appelez l'État et
lui
dire vous me donez cette rente je
connais mon Thum d'optagore par cœur je
suis dans mes
droits je suis pas sûre que ça vous
aidera de même si vous êtes au chômage
vous avez beau rédiger les plus belles
dissertations on ne vous traitera pas de
façon plus généreuse
par contre combler nos lacunes en
finances peut nous sauver de situation
précaire c'est ici que réside la
véritable clé de la sécurité
financière à travers mes aventures j'ai
osé me dire que j'avais été chanceuse
quand on est sportive puis qu'on a
allité plusieurs jours à l'hôpital qu'on
ne peut plus marcher on prend enfin le
temps de
réfléchir
et là je me suis dit et si tu n'avais
pas eu cette éducation
financière et si tu n'avais pas fait des
économies et des investissements te
permettant de te
dépatouiller c'est là que je me suis dit
que peu importe mon état de santé je
continuerai développer mon projet
d'éducation en
finances car vous savez même dans un
pays aussi renommé pour son système
financier que la Suisse il subsiste des
lacunes en matière d'éducation
financière mon expérience à la radio et
le lancement de gros projets les ont mis
en évidence de manière criante des
questions fusées comment épargner
comment investir qu'est-ce que
l'investissement en fin de
compte à travers mon projet je partage
des astuces pour épargner et pour
débuter dans
l'investissement je transmets les
erreurs que j'ai faites pour qu'elle
puisse être é et je sensibilise toute
personne n'ayant pas eu cette éducation
financière à
l'investissement comme ma Nona l'avait
fait à mes 7 ans je le fais à mes 29 ans
je contribue à démocratiser la finance
et l'investissement je sais pas si vous
l'avez reçu mais à ne châel à la sortie
du gymnase j'ai reçu ce fameux livre
s'intitulant coup de pouce pour majeur
expliquons comment se débrouiller dans
la vie d'adulte et ouais c'est fascinant
n'est-ce
pas à aucun moment du cursus on nous
avait appris à remplir notre déclaration
d'impôt ni à préparer notre retraite ni
à épargner pour les imprévus de la vie
ni à évaluer d'un investissement ni même
à faire une bonne planification
budgétaire par contre le dernier jour de
cours on nous offre ses
livres si l'on souhaite se préparer au
diff imprévu de la vie il vaut mieux
soit avoir reçu une éducation financière
de la part de nos parents soit
rechercher activement
l'information et puis choisir
dooser et ceci mesdames et messieurs est
un défi qui touche particulièrement les
femmes en Suisse si l'on regarde les 18
50 ans seulle une femme sur C
s'intéresse à la constitution d'un
patrimoine une statistique frappante qui
nous pousse à nous interroger pour
pourquoi les traditions les mœurs ce
qu'une femme a vu durant son
enfance probablement un mélange de tout
ça car qui parmi vous chers adultes se
rappelle avoir vu sa maman régler
l'addition au restaurant ou payer les
factures
d'unifamiliale très
peu cela nous mène à une réalité
profonde l'éducation que nous recevons à
la maison influence N action future
d'autant plus si elle n'est pas donnée
par l'école en l'absence d'éducation
financière nous nous raccrochons à ce
que nous voyons dès lors que notre
figure paternelle incarne la sécurité
financière et que notre figure
maternelle incarne la prudence cette
dynamique se transmet de génération en
génération comme un fardeau
invisible heureusement l'envie
s'intéresser à ses fitens personnelles
se fait de plus en plus ressentir auprès
des femmes et j'ai la chance d'être
témoin de ce changement en observant
l'audience de mon projet cependant il
reste encore beaucoup à accomplir pour
parvenir à une véritable égalité en
matière de gestion des finances le
commentaire d'une internaute m'a
d'ailleurs un jour beaucoup marqué elle
m'écrivait j'ai fait mon premier
investissement grâce à mon
copain vous pouvez imaginer ma
réaction partager entre une c'est une
joie pour cette femme qui avait osé se
lancer et une légère
frustration mais le pire dans cette
histoire est qu'il s'agit là d'un
phénomène bien plus répandu qu'on le
pense de nombreuses femmes n'osent pas
investir sans le conseil de leur
partenaire bon on va pas critiquer mais
du coup celles qui n'ont pas de copains
ou celles qui ont un copin qui
n'investit pas
elles ne sont pas préparé à affronter
les défis financiers et se trouve à la
merci de conseiller
oh parlons-en de ces conseillers
financiers vous les avez croisé n'est-ce
pas ces individus qui vous vendent des
produits peu adaptés à votre situation
mais parfaitement ajusté à leur
commission d'ailleurs devinez avec qui
j'ai préparé mon TEDx talkalk et bien un
ancien conseil en assurance et
prévoillance désormais coach
tdex
au fait je tiens à m'excuser auprès des
speakers 2024 il ne sera malheureusement
pas présent il doit être parti en
rettrit yoga suite à nos longues
discussion en l'absence d'éducation
financière nous adhérons à des produits
sans réflexion influencés par des
recommandations parfois
préjudiciables de même cette femme ayant
investi sur les conseils de son copain
avait-elle compris ce dans quoi elle
investissait je
l'espère imaginez la force qui se
déchaîne lorsque les femmes se libèrent
des entraves
financières en osant faire face au
système financier en prenant des
décisions éclairées elles tracent leur
chemin avec
audace alors mesdames aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous dire
osz vous qui êtes prudente osez vous
informer dans une économie en constante
évolution la perte d'un emploi et les
problèmes financiers frappent sans
prévenir face à ces turbulence
l'éducation financière est notre Boué de
sauvetage notre boussole dans la
tempête comme l'école ne nous prépare
pas à naviguer dans ses e troubles il
est de notre responsabilité nous doter
de ses compétences essentiell de les
partager et de les transmettre aux
générations
futures
l'éducation financière est la clé d'une
sécurité et d'une liberté financière
laissez cette clé ouvrir un avenir où
vous maîtrisez votre destin financier
mesdames et messieurs osez prendre des
mesures concrètes pour vous prémunir
vous et vos enfants contre les aléas de
la vie osez investir dans votre
éducation financière
osez agir pour garantir votre sécurité
financière à
l'avenir je m'appelle le dit j'ai 29 ans
et ma passion c'est de faire prendre
conscience aux gens qu'ils ont
l'opportunité de prendre leur avenir
financier en
main à vos investissements et merci de
m'avoir écouté ce
soir